a small column of buses attempted to
leave mariupol as the mayor urged
residents to flee the russian onslaught
but the corridor did not work as planned
according to ukraine's deputy prime
minister
a ceasefire did not hold mariupol is
still under siege the conditions there
the situation there as a result
of this russian aggression are truly
horrific throughout the day smoke could
be seen billowing from that sprawling
steel compound in the city the final
refuge for hundreds of ukrainian troops
and civilians reportedly including
canadians surrounded by russian forces
we are probably facing our last days if
not hours said this ukrainian commander
as he appealed for rescue by a third
party country
the kremlin shows no sign of backing
down as it carries out its new offensive
in a fresh sign of defiance vladimir
putin oversaw a test of a new russian
intercontinental ballistic missile which
he boasted could penetrate modern
missile defenses
food for thought he said for those who
tried to threaten our country
the west remains equally undeterred
the president of the european council
visited key then promised another 1.5
billion euros in military aid after
seeing the devastation these are
atrocities these are war crimes it must
be punished it will be punished they
must pay for what they
have done
the u.s said it would provide another
800 million dollars worth of military
equipment in the form of long-range
artillery
the pentagon will also soon begin
training ukrainian troops at a location
in europe it's meeting exactly the needs
they have at this point in the war
but help likely won't arrive soon enough
to halt the russian advances in the east
back on the streets of mariupol
residents stuck behind searched for food
and charged their phones keeping
critical connections to the outside
world working
knowing their port city may soon be
firmly in russian control
jackson prosco global news washington